[Music]
[Applause]
Paul Pierce Hall of Famer NBA champ
10-time All-Star and is the host of
Showtime's basketball weekly digital
series called ticket and the truth so
that's uh with Kevin Garnett regular
contributor to show times basketball
what's Burning series that's burned in I
threw a g at the end alongside Matt
Barnes Stephen Jackson Rachel Nichols
and Paul also contributing to the
Network's boxing coverage look at you
you're becoming a media star you got an
Empire going on here
what's going on Dad oh man I'm trying
man I'm enjoying retirement get to talk
sports uh it's been a lot of fun man I
want to go back to uh when you were
drafted so uh what was that 1999 98 yeah
90 98. okay
who bothered you the most that they were
taken ahead of you because I was looking
at the list here what's the one where
you go you got to be kidding me
well there's a couple because at the
time I didn't know who Michael Oliver
candy was we still don't know
number one and this is not a knockout
and I didn't know who Jason Williams was
at the time you know all the other guys
I knew kind of who they were because I
don't believe Jason Williams I know he
went to Florida he wasn't really touted
as a as a a top player
by the media so I was like what's you
know Oliver candied and I knew rapel and
Friends Mike baby these guys Jameson and
Vince then when Jason Williams I was
like what who was that I didn't know
what position he played or nothing
and so and then it was just like
you know I didn't know what was going on
once it got past him and then tractor
trailer and Dirk Nowitzki
tractor I didn't know who Dirk Nowitzki
was either
and I was like man that was three guys I
didn't even hear about it
where did you think you were going
I thought at worst I would go to Golden
State at worst that was the fifth pick I
believe a fourth or fifth pick at worst
you know but I thought originally I was
supposed to go number two to Vancouver
at the time which is the Memphis
Grizzlies now
and so once it got past top five I was
like
I was in the days over there I was
trying to keep a cool head but I was I
was weary in The Green Room
but you know I don't know if you keep a
chip on your shoulder because of that
how long can you keep a chip on your
shoulder
uh uh until all the coaches and general
managers are fired
a couple of them were after like my
third or fourth year I think you might
have stayed in college too long
at the time I probably did
you know but like junior year think
about it though Dan junior year was
leaving early back then yeah until
kindergarten jumped from high school you
know guys leaving early was junior year
you know and then but that year Stefan
Marbury and Sharif Abdul Rahim left as
freshmen and that kind of like the flood
games opened after that from high school
players and freshmen leaving college and
going to the Pro Who challenged you more
in your face Kobe or kg
oh man kg I have to see kg every day
when he got to Boston I mean I mean
goodness no that was like
every day and that was my boy but when
you were playing against when he was in
Minnesota
okay and Kobe's with the Lakers and then
when you would face those teams
most likely Cole because I'm matched up
more with him but I would never forget a
game to where we played Minnesota and I
know I was playing against Wally zerbiak
and I was like I was I was like having a
pretty good game and then kg switched
off on me
didn't let me touch the ball for a whole
two or three minutes and I never felt
anything like that
he denied me the ball and then at half
court I mean it was just like he he just
all defensive principles went out to
went out the window and he just didn't
want me to catch the ball
if you look at kg and I I'm always
curious about this because we want you
guys to win championships so if LeBron
leaves Cleveland all you know he's
chasing Rings or Durant leaves Oklahoma
City kg was staying in Minnesota
and yeah and he was loyal and then all
of a sudden you know Kevin McHale and
Danny Ainge make that deal but you're
like damned if you do damned if you
don't if you chase a ring we're gonna
criticize you and if you don't chase a
ring we're gonna criticize you
yeah absolutely but you know Kevin
didn't chase the ring we did it the more
you know he he got traded yeah you know
it wasn't like Oh I'm a free agent and
I'm gonna go here so it looks a little
bit different the way we put our our
pieces together then you know uh Lebron
going to Miami or or KD going to Golden
State where you know you put these
pieces together ours was kind of like we
did it the more traditional way
and so it doesn't look it is is bad I
don't think he's Paul Pierce Hall of
Famer joining us who's your vote for MVP
man this is a tough one me and kg was
talking about this yesterday and this is
this is what we came to
we're watching and be close but Giannis
is playing against
The Joker this weekend I believe
Whoever has the better game and team
wins should be MVP wow
how about we put the award at the scores
table right right if Giannis goes in
there and has like 35 and 15 and
and they win the game in Denver it goes
this is the closest I've ever seen the
race because you can really toss the
coin up and say you can give it to MB
nobody's gonna be mad you can give it
the Joker No One's Gonna Be Mad you can
give it to Giannis and nobody's is going
to be mad about it
I just think there's voter fatigue with
Joker
you know winning you know three three
times and then you put him in the
category with bird and wilts and Bill
Russell it feels like that with the
voters that they're almost realizing oh
my God he can't win it three times in a
row let's give it to indeed
yeah I mean but when you look at it the
the number's not gonna lie and when I
look at those three guys Dan
he's doing the most with the least
he doesn't have a second All-Star
because you know embiid has James Harden
who's an all-time great who should have
been All-Star
Drew holiday and Middleton are all stars
in Milwaukee we can't say that about
anybody else in Denver and he's the
number one seed in the Western
Conference which nobody had Denver being
on top of the West before the season
starts so you know it's it's gonna be
tough to not give it to him but I
understand if there is voter fatigue
we saw the uh incident last night with
the mabs and the Warriors and Mark Cuban
is probably going to get fined for his
comments and you know if it's kind of a
crazy call and then a timeout and next
thing you know Golden State's got an
easy two at the end of the third quarter
but having played the game how many
times would you go into a game and go
I'll be damn he's officiating and you
knew that he he didn't like you
man a lot you know I always would you
know the first thing let me tell you
this this is true story you can ask Mike
Gorman you know our sideline reporter
every four every game I would go to the
scores table and they say who's refering
tonight
yeah he'll he'll show me the list of the
three reps and I'll just be like oh damn
this is gonna be uh this will tell me if
it's gonna be a long night or not and
there are certain reps that didn't like
you know maybe they didn't like Doc it
was somebody that certain reps didn't
like somebody on our team or our coach
every night I felt like
but there I don't know how frustrating
is that when you're like I can't get a
call or they're gonna call you for a
foul and you didn't foul anybody
yeah but see the reason I asked before
the game is so I could be mentally
prepared to not get calls or you know
all right this is going to be a fair a
fair fight tonight so it really prepared
me just knowing coming to the game that
all right I know I can't look to expect
any calls tonight so I got to play
through that so it really helped me to
know who was rev before the game you got
any grudges that you still hold against
players
and he grudges against players yeah no I
don't have any grudges anymore man I
know I know it may seem like uh I don't
like certain players but no I don't have
I don't have any grudges man I I I think
these guys are are they put their
they sacrificed so much for the game of
basketball and you know their families
that you know I could never hold grudges
what about 10 years ago did you have
some grudges
ten years ago when I was in the game
well I just played like I didn't like
anybody you know
but it wasn't a grudge I just didn't
like you that day when we played against
each other you didn't like LeBron
I actually respected LeBron more than
anybody but he always brought the best
in me yeah and it was easy to not like
them because you know he he put up these
historic games all the time on me so I
was just like
geez I wish I was his age maybe I could
have kept up with him a little more
you can see and hear more of Paul
Showtime basketball's weekly digital
Series tickets and the truth and you can
bet there's a lot of opinions there with
kg and a regular contributor to Showtime
basketballs what's Burning uh Matt
Barnes Stephen Jackson Rachel Nichols I
think I might have been at a strip club
one night and Stephen Jackson was there
in Indianapolis
and I made it out alive Paul
if Stephen Jackson there you're gonna
definitely make it out alive he got you
I don't know uh but I think I survived
that one night uh hey great to talk to
you congrats on the career there or the
second career and thanks for joining us
oh thank you Dan always a pleasure
that's Paul Pierce Hall of Famer there